ELIZABETH ANCARANA: So we
have four faculty members,
your colleagues here today.
Two are associate
professors, and two
are tenured faculty members.
And so we thought it would
be helpful for each of them
to provide some remarks
on helpful advice
that they would give you from
their various academic career
stages on navigating life
and your professional path
as a scholar at Harvard.
So we're going to
start with Gina Kim.
Jinah Kim is the Gardner
Cowles Associate Professor
of History of Art
and Architecture
in the faculty of
Arts and Sciences.
She's trained as
an art historian
of South and Southeast
Asia with an emphasis
on Buddhist material.
Her research and publications
explore a wide range of topics,
from issues of female
representation and patronage
of art in medieval South
Asia to reappropriation
of religious sites and objects
in post-colonial contexts
of South and Southeast Asia.
Jinah's first book,
Receptacle of The Sacred--
Illustrated Manuscripts
and the Buddhist Book Cult
in South Asia earned the Bernard
Cohen Prize honorable mention
in 2015.
Her second monograph, Garlands
of Visions-- color, tantra,
and a material history
of Indian painting,
demonstrates how pothi
manuscripts transformed
Indian painting into
a portable media that
can transform a vast amount
of visual knowledge in color.
She's also developing a digital
humanities project on color
which will serve as a searchable
open database for research
on pigments.
Jinah received her Bachelor
of Arts in Archeology and Art
History from Seoul National
University and both
a master's degree in and
a PhD in History of Art
from the University of
California at Berkeley.
From her perspective as
an associate professor,
Jinah will talk about finding
resources for scholarship
and research, navigating
Harvard and your department,
managing work and life,
and pleasures of being
on the faculty at Harvard.
After Jinah provides
remarks, we'll
turn to Nicole Maestas, who
is an associate professor
of Health Care Policy at
Harvard Medical School
and a research associate
of the National Bureau
of Economic Research,
where she also
serves as the director of NBER's
Disability Research Center.
Her research studies how the
health and disability insurance
systems affect individual
economic behaviors
such as labor supply and the
consumption of medical care.
Nicole's work has shown how the
federal disability insurance
system discourages employment
by people with disabilities.
She's also examining how
population aging affects
economic growth and how
working conditions affect
individual's ability and
desire to sustain employment
at older ages.
Nicole earned a Bachelor of
Arts in English and Spanish
from Wellesley
College, a Master's
of Public Policy from the
Goldman School of Public
Policy at UC Berkeley
and a PhD in Economics
also from UC Berkeley.
From her perspective
as a recently promoted
associate professor, Nicole
will talk about priority
setting and managing your
workload and work and life.
Then we'll turn to
Matthew Weinzierl.
Matt Weinzierl is the Joseph
and Jacqueline Elbing Professor
of Business Administration
in the Business, Government,
and the international Economy
Unit at Harvard Business
School, and he's also a research
associate at the National
Bureau of Economic Research.
His academic
research has largely
focused on the optimal
design of economic policy
and the role of
government in the economy.
His current projects
identify and formalize
the goals for tax
policy that hold
sway among the
public, political,
and economic leaders
and leading tax thinkers
and then characterize
the implications of using
those objectives in the
analysis of optimal taxation.
Recently, Matt
has launched a set
of research projects focused
on the commercialization
of the space sector and
its economic implications.
Matt didn't earn his
degrees from Berkeley.
However, he earned a
Bachelor of Arts and a PhD,
both in Economics, from
Harvard University.
From his vantage point as
a recently tenured faculty
member, Matt will
provide to those
who've not spent time at Harvard
before advice on what you might
want to know about
the university
when joining the faculty here.
And finally, Hopi Hoekstra is
the Alexander Agassiz Professor
of Zoology, jointly appointed
in the Departments of Molecular
and Cellular Biology and
Organismic and Evolutionary
Biology.
She's also an investigator
with the Howard Hughes Medical
Institute and the
curator of mammals
in the Museum of
Comparative Zoology.
Hopi also serves on
the FAS's Committee
on Appointments and Promotions,
otherwise known as CAP.
As an evolutionary
geneticist, Hopi
studies the molecular basis
of adaptation in wild mice.
Her work spans the fields
of evolution, behavior,
morphology, genetics, genomics,
development, and neurobiology.
She has received many awards
for her research and teaching,
including the Richard Lounsbery
Award from the National
Academy of Sciences,
election into the National
Academy of Sciences, the
Fannie Cox Prize for Teaching
Excellence, and an appointment
to a five-year Harvard College
professorship.
Alas, Hopi does hold a
BA in integrative biology
from the University
of California Berkeley
and a PhD in zoology from
the University of Washington.
From her vantage point
as a tenured faculty
member at Harvard, Hopi
will talk about resources
for teaching and mentoring
and managing your workload
and life.
Jinah?
JINAH KIM: All right.
Thank you, Elizabeth, for
that wonderful introduction.
And good afternoon, everyone.
While I was just introduced,
my name is Jinah Kim,
and I teach history or art.
I'm in history of
art and architecture
in Arts and Humanities
Division in FAS.
And I'm excited to see
so many new colleagues
in our division,
Arts and Humanities,
and also including one
in my own department
and in FAS and all other
professional schools.
And when Judy asked me to be
on this new faculty institute,
I readily agreed,
because I found
it very helpful when
I joined this campus
like five years ago.
And also because
I've got so much
help from her office and
also all the resources
available to Harvard
faculty on this campus.
And I felt I should share.
And so I was speaking about--
I just condensed it
into three aspects
of finding resources for
scholarship and research
and maybe a little bit
about managing work and life
and pleasures of the
faculty position at Harvard.
So finding resources for
scholarship and research--
and you will find
there is a good amount
of administrative
support on this front.
I'll just speak from
being faculty on FAS
that we have the FAS
Research Development
Office that can help
you find funding
sources for your projects.
When I was developing
this exhibition project
on Nepalese Buddhist
ritual art, I really
needed to find funding
to support this project.
And I met with folks at the
FAS research development,
and they did all this
research and came up
with all these resources
that I could apply internally
and externally.
And they were super helpful.
And that is, in a way, time
saving for your own research
and work that you will do.
And I'm sure there are other
services campus-wide that's
available like that.
But for me, finding resources
for research and scholarship
is intimately tied
to really navigating
Harvard and your department,
because the possibility to tap
into the resources, the
human resources, the eminent
scholars that are now
your campus colleagues,
and being able to
connect with them
for new possibilities
and research engagement
is just enormous.
However, in practical
terms, as everyone
has been talking about,
making connections
on the Harvard campus takes
extra efforts and time.
I think more so than
some other campuses.
So this is partly because
everyone is so busy,
them being eminent and
very popular and on demand.
And we joke about how you
will hear your colleagues
speak at some other
big universities
but not in your own
department, because you just
don't get to have that kind of
chance, and they're so busy.
And you have to make that extra
effort to schedule meetings
and coffee and lunch.
And I was looking back
on-- so in preparation
for this institute,
I was looking back
on my calendar for fall 2013.
And I realized,
there are just so
many meetings, lunch meetings,
tea, coffee meetings,
with all these faculty members
in my department and elsewhere.
And this is partly
thanks to the advice
I was given by a
senior faculty member
on this campus who
said, make sure
that you meet with your
senior members or members
of your department and
have individual meetings.
You really connect with them.
And I try.
I didn't get to do all
of them in one year,
because everyone goes on
leave, and it's just hard.
And my list of to do, of
having to have lunch with list
keeps growing.
But it is a great
chance to introduce
yourself and your work and
learn about their research
and interests.
And the unspoken
rules for new faculty
seems to be that senior
colleagues and colleagues who
have been here
often take you out
for a meal or coffee for
all these initial meetings
as a welcome.
So it's a free lunch.
So always invite
yourself for a meeting.
And I'm happy to take anyone
out for lunch or coffee.
So I will do the same,
because I've been always given
these opportunities.
And one of the unique aspects
of Harvard that was iterated all
year is that-- and it took
a while for me to comprehend
actually, by heart--
is how much autonomy
and independence
each academic department has.
And this system really ensures
that each academic unit
keeps its integrity
and really sustains
a kind of excellence
while promoting
deep scholarship in each field.
But downside of this
is that it can also
be a barrier that
blocks connecting
with scholars and experts
outside your immediate fields.
And you will notice there is
no shortage of scholarly events
on Harvard campus.
When I arrived on this
campus five years ago,
the senior scholar in
the Cambridge residence
mentioned to me that
Harvard is like a Disneyland
for scholarly minds.
And I think that's
sort of an apt analogy.
Just there are a number of
exciting and interesting talks
and symposium at any given time.
On the other hand, because
of this siloed nature
of its academic
units, sometimes one
does not get to learn
about it or know
about this scholar
giving a talk or there
is an event that's really
crucial to your own research
that is happening until the
day of or after it's over,
which is quite a loss, actually.
So for example, an eminent
Buddhist studies scholar
was giving a talk on campus,
and I learned about it
like two days before the talk.
And I barely managed to
make parts of that event.
But if people and scholars
in Buddhist studies
known about my research
interest in Sanskrit Buddhist
manuscripts and
Tantric Buddhism,
they might have
actually alerted me
that somebody working
on that is coming.
And I would have actually
arranged the meeting in advance
when he was just here
briefly from Hamburg.
So I'm not about to go out
to see him, but if he's here,
I might as well have seen him.
So my point being, the
more people on campus
know about your research
interests, the better
your chances of
getting connected
with scholarly resources.
And you think now
you're at Harvard,
everyone should know
what you're working on.
That's not the case.
And you need to be
your own spokesperson,
and that's really important.
And of course, the
campus-wide gatherings
that Judy's office provides
are really great opportunities
to meet and connect
with scholars who are
working outside your own field.
And I also recommend looking up
all these institutes, centers,
that are so cognate in
your cognitive fields
and making efforts to connect
with them, because even
just signing off for the
event letters or newsletters
is actually helpful to know
about these events going on
around the campus.
And you can decide to go
or not to go, but at least
just to actually have
an understanding of what
goes on around the campus
is actually helpful.
And I thought I would
be part of these groups.
But it's not automatic you would
be plugged into these existing
communities.
You really do need
to make efforts to be
connected to these resources.
So in my first year here,
I organized an event
on Nepal and a talk on
Southeast Asian art, let's say.
And I reached out to
South Asia Institute,
now named Lakshmi Mittal and
Family South Asia Institute,
the executive director,
basically asking for money,
right?
And I really needed funding
to sponsor these events.
And that actually was the
beginning of many collaborative
efforts which culminated
in my hosting my field
symposium on the
Harvard campus, which
really was a great success.
And being part of
this institute,
which actually is kind of
result of this one unit,
"one Harvard" effort,
that I can also get
plugged into many
different networks
that I would have not access to.
And being part of and being
plugged into these networks
are really important doing
research in South Asia.
I don't know how
many of you actually
do research outside the US.
But if you actually have to
go somewhere and do research,
you really do need connections.
And it really serves to have
these kind of connections
well established.
And of course, Harvard
name does carry weight
when representing
serious research.
So you do get a lot more access.
There is no doubt about that.
But having these
connections that
are really concrete that can
introduce you to these people
can actually open archives and
reserve collections that would
never be have been accessible.
And of course, the
Mittal Institute being
part of this "one
Harvard" motto,
I get to actually meet
people from Kennedy School,
public health, business
school, medical schools, GSD,
School of Education.
So it's a great milieu where
I can actually talk to people
and learn about their
exciting projects.
And in fact, given
this opportunity
of having all these scholars
from different schools,
I will actually shamelessly
plug in my project on this.
This is total humanities project
on mapping color and history,
because I'm discovering
this is really
trying to create a
online database that
is searchable on historical
and scientific information
on pigments in these paintings.
And I'm discovering this
is so hard to deal with,
not having any background on
data science or statistics.
And I heard a lot of data
science and statistics
in the crowd.
Any of you experts, I would
love to talk to you afterwards.
So it's just making these
kinds of connections.
And finding centers
that you can help set
can actually connect you through
these different nodal points
I think are really important.
And you need to
make that effort.
So my basic attitude in
advancing scholarship
and research is really to ask,
to ask and to ask, shamelessly
ask.
And whether it's for funding
or any other connections
you need, and you
will find an answer.
I'll talk a little bit
about managing work and life
from the perspective
of a working
mother of a 10-year-old boy
who constantly sort of suspects
that his mother loves
her work more than him.
And I arrive on this campus
with a five-year-old son.
And my husband
works in New York,
so that presents a challenging
situation for child care.
And the child care
and funding supports
that come from Judy's
office-- and also,
FAS has funding support-- and
these are all very helpful.
And I did use the dependent care
fund to travel internationally
to give talks.
And I had to take
my child with me.
And that was a great support.
And I have to say, as much
as my 10-year-old likes
to give me a hard
time by saying,
you love your work
more than you love me,
but he loves being part
of my work and research.
I have to say.
And he, from the
tender age of four,
he said he would be my research
assistant and help Mommy.
And finally, on the pleasure
of being on Harvard faculty,
and in addition to these
incredible resources
and scholarly assets,
I'd say working
with these exceptional
students are just phenomenon.
It is phenomenal
to be working with
these exceptional students.
When I taught a freshman
seminar in one fall,
I was just so stunned by the
amount and quality of the work
that freshmen produced.
And this sort of leads to the
last tip I will share here,
which my department
colleague, Jennifer Roberts,
shared with us at my new faculty
institute, which is to say,
you should design your courses
to advance your research.
And don't try to teach a new
course every year, because it
will take a while to figure out
the demographic and the needs
of the course, of any course.
And I think other
panels would touch
upon the work-life balance
and managing your time,
but I'd like to add that
it takes really discipline
to be protective of your
research and writing time.
And as much as I emphasized
reaching out, collaborating,
being part of an active
member of the community,
at the end of the day,
your scholarly contribution
does require a lot of
these solitary moments.
And this really
requires discipline.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
NICOLE MAESTAS:
Hello, so I'm Nicole.
I'm an economist at
Harvard Medical School.
I've been here for
about three years.
And I came as an
associate professor.
So I have six pieces
of advice for you
based on my experience
of being new.
And I kind of marvel at this,
because I still feel new,
and maybe I am compared
to many others here.
But here goes.
OK, and some of these
are going to echo
things you'll hear from others
that you have heard so far.
But my first very important
one is simply meet people.
Now, this is why
many of us are here.
We came to Harvard
because of the people.
It's an incredible place
filled with incredible people.
And believe me, it is
layers deep in terms
of opportunity, experience,
potential collaborators.
It's like an onion.
It will take you years to
kind of unpeel that onion.
But now is really the
only time you'll ever
be a new professor at Harvard.
It goes so fast.
It's gone in a flash.
Next thing you know, you're
sitting on a panel like this.
And trust me, you'll
be far too busy
then to invest the kind
of time you could put now
into meeting people later on.
But I promise you,
if you invest early,
it will pay dividends
down the line.
Make a list of names.
Work your list.
If you're an introvert, just
force yourself to do it.
Calendar it.
Schedule those meetings.
Invite someone for lunch.
And the important
thing to realize
is that people actually
expect to hear from you.
They really do.
And if you don't reach
out, they might wonder why.
Just do it.
For me, it was
important that I met
other economists, economists
at the other schools.
I also work a bit in
the field of aging.
It was important to meet
other non-economists working
on aging across the schools.
And there are so many
of them, but again,
not just within your
discipline, but across schools
and across other disciplines.
I recommend the events
held by the university,
held by Judy's office,
held by Radcliffe,
by all the other various
centers around here.
These are great ways to meet
people that you otherwise
wouldn't naturally meet.
I figure that if I've
met one new person
and had an authentic
interaction with that person
at an event like that that
it was a good use of my time.
And just to give you an
example, I attended since--
my office is in the
Longwood campus,
but since I was here
today, I went to an event
at the Harvard Kennedy
School and met my one person.
He was a senior
faculty member that I
had admired for a long time
in the sociology department.
And I had my chance.
It wouldn't have happened
if I hadn't just shown up.
Side tip-- flights out of
Boston to just about anywhere,
but especially DC, are
loaded with Harvard faculty.
I have had some of
my best interactions
just by talking to
the person next to me
on a flight out of Boston.
So anyway, it's a very
efficient way to meet somebody.
Now people often say that
it takes too much time
to get to events.
And it is true it can
take a bit of time,
but you need to kind of
recognize that upfront
and just work around it.
As I mentioned, my
office is in Longwood.
A short time after
I arrived here,
someone offered me
a desk in Cambridge.
In fact, I had multiple
offices for desks in Cambridge.
So if they come, grab them.
I jumped on this offer, and
I now have a place to sit.
I sat there today knowing
that I wanted to be here
for this event today.
But it just makes it easier
to meet with anybody.
It reduces the time
costs, and that's
what you're really looking for
is a way to reduce those travel
and time costs.
I have faculty members,
maybe faculty colleagues,
they might not have
an office to sit at.
But they have their spot.
It's a special cafe in Cambridge
or a place in the library.
And that'll be where they go.
Actually, it's kind of nice.
You get some kind of quiet
time and a change of scene
for a day to enable you
to do some of the things
in different part of campus.
OK, I promise the rest won't
be quite as long as that.
Number two, figure out what
are the most important things
for you to accomplish
in your new role.
OK, now, no matter
what level you're
at in the academic
ladder, there's
always a next step on
that trajectory for you.
And even for two people at
the same spot, that next step
might be might be different.
Figure It out early,
and figure it out
by talking to the people who
will actually make decisions
about whether or not you're
fulfilling those goals.
But even more
important than that,
figure out where you are
relative to the goal.
So, early on, I heard from
my other associate professor
colleagues in the
medical school that it
was very important
to demonstrate
international influence
for promotion.
And I observed them
traveling all around
and giving international talks.
So I went hog wild and lined up
a bunch of international talks
and spent a lot of
time on airplanes
going and giving talks.
It wasn't clear to me
that I'd kind of already
done enough of that until
my chair said to me,
why are you traveling so much?
So the point just being that
what's right for somebody
is not necessarily the
thing that you need.
And in my instance, I
had taken care of that.
That was in good shape,
and that time was better
put on something else.
Number three, once
you find out what
the most important
things are for you,
make those things sacrosanct.
OK, for me, it's
about protecting time
to do the things that feed into
those most important things.
So for me and for many
of us, writing time
is really the thing, right?
So for me, I write
in the mornings,
and I do not take
meetings in the mornings
unless I absolutely have to.
It's just a rule.
I have an assistant
who schedules
my meetings with
all my colleagues
and project staff and the like.
And everybody knows that I don't
take meetings in the mornings
because that's when I write.
And it's just
arbitrary, but it works.
The other thing to
recognize about that,
though, is that often things
sort of change over time.
And I used to work and
live on the West Coast.
So my writing time
was in the afternoon,
because I needed to talk
to people on the East Coast
in the mornings.
OK, so be flexible,
but figure it out.
So number four, optimize
your schedule for you.
OK, we're all
different, but you need
to figure out how you're
going to do your best work
and when you do your best work.
I find that how I
start my day determines
how the rest of the day goes.
If I start out focused
writing a paper,
then I tend to do
more writing that day.
But if I start my
day answering emails,
I tend to get caught up in
the administrative stuff,
and I spend less time
writing that day.
I also wind up frittering
away the time of day
that's most productive for me.
Now, I used to be most
productive like after 10:00 PM.
That's no longer the case.
For me, my most productive time
is first thing in the morning.
Another small thing,
but if I drive to work,
I find I arrive tired.
If I take the train,
I arrive more awake,
because I've had to walk 15
minutes to get from the station
to my office.
These small details can
make a really big difference
in how you start the
day, and that really
sets you on a trajectory.
It's important to recognize
those small things that
can make that difference.
OK, number five,
find your boundaries.
Many of us experienced
an exponential increase
in invitations and opportunities
after arriving at Harvard.
For me, it was absolutely
overwhelming at times.
It's just one example,
and it's a small one,
but I began getting so many
requests for [? review ?]
reports from journals, for
grant review committees, letters
for people who were
up for promotion,
that I felt that if I
accepted all of them,
I could spend all my time
commenting on other people's
work instead of
actually doing my work.
So it goes without
saying that you need
to figure out when to say no.
OK, something has
to give, and you
have to recognize that
really early if it's
something you should do.
And it's often
good to get advice
from the people who know
what really matters for you,
back to item number
two on the list.
If it's something
you really should do,
then you ask yourself,
OK, what am I
going to cross off my list in
order to make room for that?
It's really important to
do that, because many of us
just acquire more and more
service activities as life
goes on without actually letting
go of things that we've already
done, that we've
already mastered.
And another thing
is that many people
think that you have to
give an explanation when
you say no to an activity.
But really, you don't.
You just say no.
Nobody really cares.
They don't need to hear why.
Mostly they just
want a timely no so
they can move on
to the next person,
and there is always
a next person.
Make time to keep yourself
happy and healthy.
This job isn't
everything in life.
Self care matters.
And it matters an
incredible amount.
You have to exercise.
You have to sleep.
Your family matters.
Your friends matter.
In my case, I found
that moving here
from another place-- before
this, I lived in Los Angeles.
I arrived here without friends.
And I still to this day am
working on finding things
in this new city, but it
takes a lot of effort when
you're very busy with--
I have three kids and
this job and the like.
But these sorts of
things are really
essential for sustaining a
good pace over a long horizon.
OK, so with that,
I will leave you
with parting words
which are, above all,
don't be too serious about
things and just have fun.
[APPLAUSE]
MATTHEW WEINZIERL:
Can I just stand up?
Thank you.
Hello, I'm Matt.
I'm with the business school.
And we teach very
interactively, so I have
to be able to see all of you.
It's just a bug in the system.
OK, so we have a colleague
from the philosophy department.
So I have a question to ask
Samantha, I believe, right?
So why did the dolphin join
the philosophy department when
she came to Harvard University?
To discover her
porpoise in life.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, very good,
that was terrible.
Come on, people, seriously.
OK, don't take
yourself too seriously.
Did you hear Nichole's
last piece of advice?
All right, so I have--
I'm not really sure why
exactly I was invited here
to give you my thoughts,
although I have been here
quite a while.
So I came here from
Minnesota, where I grew up,
when I was 18 for undergrad.
That was '96.
A couple of years in New York
and a year in DC in between,
but otherwise, I was
here for grad school too.
So I've been at
Harvard literally half
of my life, which is
kind of an amazing thing.
And so even though it's
still just one perspective,
at least it's a perspective
I've kind of evolved over time.
So that's what
I'm hoping to give
you are some thoughts about
how this place feels to someone
who's been here for a while.
And as our colleagues
were talking,
I kept writing more things
I wanted to tell you.
So I'm going to try to go
fast so that I don't go over
my time.
But the first thing is,
I was the only one who
wasn't asked to speak about
work and life balance,
but I'm going to anyways.
[LAUGHTER]
ELIZABETH ANCARANA:
We knew that.
[LAUGHTER]
MATTHEW WEINZIERL:
And I would say--
the most important thing I
would say about balancing work
and life is balance
your work and life.
Actually do it.
It's important.
I actually don't think
it's as much of a trade off
as your instinct is
telling you it is.
I think the more you balance
your family or your friends
with your work, the
more creative you are,
the broader a thinker
you are, probably
the happier and
healthier you are.
And so even though, of
course, you will feel bad
if you don't get
tenure, and you'll
wonder like, if I just
spent more sleepless nights
in the office.
I think you'll feel even
worse if you do get tenure,
and you don't know your
spouse or your kids.
I think that's an
even worse outcome.
So just remember that
as you're going on.
And I have to say,
I'm not just saying
this for a self-serving
reason but actually also
to leave at 4:45 to go
pick up my daughter.
So please forgive
me for doing that.
OK, now, my three things
that I had prepared
before though, the
first one, thoughts
about Harvard University--
I'm not sure it's a
particularly friendly thought,
so brace yourselves
a little bit.
I would say that I think Harvard
expects you to define yourself,
and that can sometimes be hard.
So I want to give
you a little example.
Five years ago or so, I got
promoted to associate, which
is, of course, without tenure.
And so I met with our department
head to sort of debrief.
And this should be a
happy occasion, all right,
congratulations, all this stuff.
It was not.
So he was a very
senior macroeconomist.
Unfortunately, he's
no longer with us.
And he sat me down.
And he said, so, Matt,
here's how I see it.
You've chosen to play in
a subfield of economics
that has attracted many of their
highest IQ people in the field.
You're not going to
win in that field.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, that was sobering,
because, of course, implicitly,
he's saying something
about my IQ, right?
We all got that part.
But also, look, I'd just been
promoted to associate, which
means I have four
years, basically,
three, till a packet goes in,
until to make tenure, right?
And it was hard at first.
But then as I look
back on it, I think
it was some of the
best advice I got.
Because, first of all it, was
right, the fact part of it
about the IQ.
But more importantly, it forced
me to say, what can I do?
In economist speak, what's
my comparative advantage?
What can I actually do at
this place that will earn me
tenure in a few years?
What do I bring to the table?
And Harvard, as loving as
it is, and Judy's office--
to be clear, I've
been here a while--
has made big
strides in making it
more of a supportive community.
It isn't exactly the
handholding place, right?
This is a place of ambition.
It's place with a lot
of hard driving people,
and the place expects you
to be one of those people.
So find your path and chart it.
And so I think that's important.
The one little caveat I would
make to that, which I actually
thought of when
Larry was talking,
was at my grad
school orientation,
President Faust gave a speech.
And she said, at some point
during grad school, each of you
will feel like you
don't belong here,
like you're a failure,
like somehow it was
a mistake that they let you in.
And I was like, that's not
going to happen to me, right?
I totally belong here.
And then two years
into grad school,
I had exactly that feeling.
It felt like, oh, my gosh, what
if I'm not going to make it?
I started calling hedge
funds to see if they'd
give me a job on Wall Street.
And so I went
through that moment.
And I would guess that that
will happen to a lot of us
as junior faculty, a lot of
you as junior faculty too.
It certainly happened
to me where you wonder,
how's this going to work out?
And all I would say
is, know that that
does happen to a lot of people
who are here as junior faculty.
And it's OK.
You can make it through.
You're here for a reason.
It's not a mistake
that you got hired.
OK, the second thing I
will go very quickly, which
is because everyone's
covered this already.
This is a big place.
That can be a challenge.
But of course, the economies
of scale are incredible.
I'm interested in the
commercialization of space.
The minute I started
talking about that, people
from all over the
university popped up
who were interested in this.
And I think that's
not an accident.
We're all interested.
We're all looking for
the big stuff, right?
So that's going to matter.
And so when you find
one of those things,
other people have
probably found it too.
So raise your hand,
and you'll meet
people who can help you
to partner with them.
OK, so the last
thing, which again,
I think it's a little
more controversial maybe.
But I'll say it.
So the university works
in what sometimes can
seem like very mysterious ways.
And you'll be tempted
to wonder about that,
but I would urge you to
think that it deserves
your help and your trust.
OK, so the trust in
particular, I think,
is going to be the
keyword for me.
So, look, as I've been here
as an undergrad and then
a grad student and an
assistant professor
and so on, at each
point, you're tempted
to think that person above you
is making some crazy mistake,
like a terrible decision.
Why would they do that?
And of course, that
is true sometimes.
Sometimes, professors or
even deans or even presidents
make mistakes.
But one thing I've
also learned as I've
taken on different positions
is that sometimes you
don't know the full
set of complexities
that that person is dealing
with in those roles.
A short a little example, so
we have these teaching groups
at the business school.
So we teach by the case
method like the law school.
And that means there's
several professor-- well,
we have these large courses.
Anyways, there's
several professors
teaching the same course.
And we get together
to discuss how we're
going to teach these cases.
And I remember as
a new professor,
we would teach a couple of cases
that I knew the year previously
had not worked very well.
Why in the world are we
teaching this thing again?
We only have 30 classes
with our students.
Why would we waste a session?
Now I'm course head for
one of those courses.
And I realize we
have a norm, which
is that when a new
professor writes a case,
we leave it in the
curriculum for two years.
OK, so no matter what
happens the first year,
you leave it in.
And it does have that cost.
Sometimes it does
not work very well.
But it's the right norm
for a couple of reasons.
It shows that we're committed
to that junior professor.
We're not throwing
them under the bus.
And it makes us work
harder as a teaching group
to figure out how to
teach difficult cases
and how to learn how to
teach cases that don't
work in an easy sort of way.
Because it's one of those
things that as course head,
you see the rest of it that you
wouldn't have seen underneath.
And that's happened to me
1,000 times at Harvard,
as I've been here
for a long time.
So to be clear, I'm not saying
the university is perfect.
If you see something,
say something.
[LAUGHTER]
But it's important, right?
You might be the first
one to spot the mistake.
But I would just have you--
I would urge you maybe to think
while you're doing that or as
you're about to do
it that it could
be that 100 other of the
brilliant people around you
have also seen that.
And they've mentioned
it, but there's
some constraint you haven't
quite understood yet.
And then that's
why the university
is doing what it does.
So Larry said this, and
I would just repeat it.
Everyone at this university
wants your colleagues
to succeed, your students
to succeed, you to succeed,
because that is the
university, right?
What is the faculty?
The faculty is your
colleagues, and it's you.
And we're in the service of
our students and our alumni.
And so we all want to
make this work together.
And so I think it
deserves our support
and our constructive
criticism and our trust.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
HOPI HOEKSTRA: [INAUDIBLE].
I think I'm going to stand
up here too because I
can see only half of you.
Great, thanks for
letting me go last.
So I guess I'm the most senior.
I've been here-- can
you guys hear me?
I've been here for
about 12 years now.
And as Elizabeth mentioned,
I'm part of FAS, OEB, MCB, MCZ,
HBI, CBS, HHMI,
and I serve on CAP.
So as you guys already
probably have figured out,
the first challenge
you're going to have
is figuring out all the
acronyms at this place.
It's incredible.
I'm still figuring
them all out myself.
I did want to mention
one thing to reiterate
what Elizabeth said.
And that is, I serve on CAP,
and that's the Committee
of Appointments and Promotions.
And so I want to mention
this for two reasons.
But the first thing to
say is that I'm really
excited to see you here.
So for those of you who
came through tenure,
and you're at FAS, I
know a lot about you.
I've read your files.
I've read some of your papers.
We've had discussions
about you, and it's
great to see your faces.
For those of you who are
on tenure track, at least
through FAS, I look forward
to seeing your dossiers
in about eight years.
So this is one of the most fun
committees that I've served on.
I feel a lot of responsibility,
and we take our jobs
very seriously.
But I just wanted to put at
least one of the several faces
behind that committee
who makes decisions--
or sorry, we make no decisions.
We make recommendations
about tenures and promotion.
So just to see a face
behind that committee,
because I know when
I first arrived here,
I thought a lot about
tenure, and I thought a lot
about that process.
And there were some mysterious
steps along the way,
and CAP was one of them.
So I was tasked with telling
you a little bit about teaching
and teaching resources
here on campus.
So the first thing I'll say,
I'm wearing my cap of CAP.
And that is that teaching is
taken really seriously in terms
of tenure and promotion.
And I don't think
that's just lip service.
I can say on the CAP
committee that maybe half
of the discussion for
each person's dossier
is really about the
contributions to teaching.
And so it's something
that I think
it's good to hear early
on and to really digest,
because I think
that a lot of advice
you get from people who went
through tenure 20 years ago
or people from the
outside of Harvard,
you'll hear it's
all about research.
But it's really about
research and teaching.
And on a more sort
of happy note,
not thinking about tenure, is I
think this is a fantastic place
to be a teacher.
Because I think
that, within reason,
you're really only limited
by your imagination.
Harvard hired you
for your creativity
not just in research,
but also in teaching.
And I'd like to think that you
came here, chose to come here,
for this environment.
There are a ton of resources
available to help you
with teaching.
I am still learning
about all of them.
So I'm just going
to mention a few.
And again, this is really
going to be FAS focused,
because that's my home.
I just wanted to give
you the perspective
that I teach in a large
introductory genetics course.
I have between 300
and 400 freshmen.
And I do want to reiterate
the point that teaching
freshmen here is the best.
They're great, wide eyed,
super eager, excited, slightly
freaked out.
But so the first resource
I wanted to mention
is the Bok Center.
The Bok Center is
the place to go
when you are thinking
about teaching,
when you want to kick
off a new course,
you have a project, even
when you just have an idea.
There are people
literally waiting for you
to come to them, and all
they want to do is help.
They're great people
to bounce ideas off of,
talk about courses,
designing new courses,
syllabi, everything.
They will help you
with everything,
and they can't wait to help you.
They will also be of great
help if you're struggling.
So if you run your
first course, and it
didn't go as smoothly as you
expected, which happens a lot,
they are there.
They will come to your class.
They will videotape you.
They will make you
watch that video.
They will give you
advice, et cetera.
They will also
help your students.
So if you have maybe
not a 300 person course,
but you have a smaller course,
and you want the students
to run projects, to
make their own videos,
to do hands-on projects, you
can send them to the Bok Center
with--
you have to get
pre-approved, of course.
Send them to the Bok Center,
and they will help them
with those projects.
And then importantly, they also
can help you with assessment,
so learning about if you are
doing a good job teaching,
as good as you think
you're doing, right?
So I just wanted to give you one
quick example from the course
that I was teaching in, or
I have been teaching in,
for the last five years.
And that is we
decided that instead
of having sort of
review sessions,
we would make videos,
two, three minute videos,
of difficult concepts, the
concepts that students struggle
with every term.
And so we had this idea.
We went to the Bok Center, and
we said, is this a good idea?
They worked with us and
made it a better idea.
Then we were able to get money.
So this is another
point I wanted to make
is that there are
pots of money around
to help you with teaching.
So we used course
innovation funds.
And I sent an email
to the assistant dean
of undergraduate education,
and we got more money
from a different pot to hire
somebody who made these videos.
But then what she
wanted to do was
turn making videos into a
project in and of itself.
And then she recruited not
only our teaching fellows
but undergraduates who
would test these videos.
And now we have this
library of 20 or so videos
of these difficult concepts.
The really good ones
we'll keep for next year.
We'll make some new ones.
This is now an idea that other
courses are starting to adopt.
And it's been just a super
exciting and fun project
that we could have,
and I certainly
couldn't have done on my own.
But with the help
of the Bok Center,
these little pots of money,
and then lots of imagination
and energy, it came to be.
Another resource that
I want to mention,
and you've probably already
started getting emails from,
is HILT, Harvard Initiative
for Learning and Teaching.
See, another acronym.
They run an annual single
day conference, usually
in the fall, that
has different topics.
And so you'll hear
some amazing speakers
that specialize in how to
teach, how to teach well.
And then usually we break
out into small lunches
and little workshops.
And you can choose among
a variety of topics
that are most relevant to you.
This is another great
way to meet colleagues.
I've certainly met several
colleagues through that.
And then HILT also
then funds projects.
So if you have an idea,
an innovative idea,
in terms of teaching,
this is another way
that you can get money
to support that idea.
All of that said,
I've found that one
of my most valuable resources
in thinking about teaching
is my colleagues.
So in the MCB department,
Molecular and Cellular Biology
department, we have
a program in which
colleagues come
to your lectures,
watch, and provide feedback.
We do this on an optional
basis if you're tenured.
I did it.
I got great feedback
even post-tenure.
But we do it for all our
tenure track faculty.
It's a great way not only
to get feedback and improve
your courses, but you have your
colleagues get to know you.
And when they write letters
in support of your tenure,
they have more to say
than just your research.
They can comment directly
on your teaching as well.
And one of the things that
I learned from my colleagues
that I think was most
exciting about teaching here
is that there's a
great opportunity
to be super creative.
You can do sort of whatever
you want in terms of teaching.
And so I just wanted to
give you two quick examples
of some courses that I
developed when I first got here.
The first one I taught was
a graduate level course
on speciation, so
how new species form.
And this was a course
that we were going
to read the primary literature.
And so as we were
thinking about this,
I picked a couple of faculty
and a couple of their papers
from across the world.
And we would talk about
each one of those topics
over the course of 12 weeks.
And they started
thinking about this
like running a journal club.
The students would
ask me questions
like, well, why did they
do the experiment this way?
Or why did they choose that?
Or why does this
figure look like this?
I didn't actually know.
So what we decided to do
was to Skype the professors.
And so this is now
not so new anymore.
Lots of places do this.
But 12 years ago when we
first started doing this,
it was a lot of fun.
And it got a lot of
support to do teaching
in kind of a new way
using video conferencing
to talk to the primary sources.
Another example was
that I'm a curator
of mammals in the Natural
History Museum here.
And I had four freshmen knock
on my door one day and say, hey,
there's a course on birds.
There's a course on herpetology.
But there's no
course on mammals.
Let's have a course on mammals.
And so we designed a course.
And they designed the
syllabus themselves.
They had designed
their own projects.
And at the end of
that year, what
we decided to do
as our end of year
project was go into
the collections
and actually revise all of
the nomenclature for all
of the species in the
Great Mammal Hall--
which I encourage you all
to go see, 26 Oxford Street.
It's a rare gem on campus.
And this was a
hands-on experience.
They were out in the museum.
And we actually had
to move specimens,
because some of the
systematic relationships
actually changed since
that was first installed.
So it was a lot of fun.
So I encourage you to
be really creative.
And I think that creativity
is really valued here.
I think the main thing that I
want to leave you with in terms
of teaching is that for every
problem, issue, question
that you have, there is
someone here to help you.
And I think the big
challenge is starting
to learn where to find the right
people to answer your question.
So they exist, and you
just have to find them.
I think I'm not going to
comment just so that there's
time for questions
on work life balance.
And I agree with everything
that was said previously.
And it's worth
putting in the time
to figure out your
work life balance now
and getting good habits
now because those
are the habits you're going
to have 12 years later.
Great, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ELIZABETH ANCARANA: Thank
you again to all of you.